okay so chit chat number three
if you are finding these these of
interest
i'm hoping at some stage to make
podcasts and perhaps these would would
have been better in a podcast but you
can just listen to them you don't have
to watch me sitting here talking
but of course for the pictures
it's better to see up on film
okay so i've got my spirit guide
and uh
i'm convinced that
he's with me
and what i do is when i want to ask a
question or have a problem in life
rather than
mess my head up thinking oh what should
i do what should i do
i go into
a small trance
and
i connect with him
i always know the connection
he he always comes from the right and he
just gives me a little breeze it's just
like a
just like that
that's even stronger than the fear i
look at but there's always some
indication
and
if you
wish to
connect with your own spirit guide if
you
wish to believe this
then you must ask
for a sign
and you might get something in your
eyebrows you might get you might feel
like you had a little general thinker
press you somewhere there will be
something that you will know
knowing you're fine be notified with
if you think that you're doubtful
pause ask again
and and if you think oh i think that was
the same
but you will get this connection
trying too hard can sometimes
block it so you don't get this but once
you get used to
what i call going into trance
you will get this i'm just going to
quickly just show you but i'll talk as
if
you know someone else was talking
through this because i can't go into
real trance and talk
i'll wait for my breath to be calm
and i wait for my mind also to become
the most desirable
place i need to get to
his peacefulness within myself
a peacefulness
of not searching
nor even like a butterfly
hopping from one leaf to the other
flapping its wings
but to rest
on the flower
and to just leave its wings open
that's where i'm trying to get to
at that point there will be nothing
perhaps on your split second
but there will be nothing
happening whatsoever
you'll be in a complete moment of
stillness
and talk with your mind
and because you at the first time you
may not know what side your guide will
be
connecting with you
don't expect
the right or the left
and don't expect just because your right
or left-handed
they will come to that side
but mine is on the right
so
with telepathy on my
mind because i'm connected to my soul
spiritually
so i'm talking
like a
triangular thought
so i'm sending out a message
to my guide
to say
please connect
and show me
that you're there
wait not anxiously
but in that moment of calm
if you've moved from that moment of calm
try to go back to that moment of calm
where the butterfly's settled
and the wings are open
you may wish to say
can you help me with
the thought that is troubling me right
now
you can even expand
to say
can you help me with what's troubling me
in the current situation of
let's say my family one particular
person you might want wish to not name
them
you might
be going through
health problems
can you tell me
what i can do
to help myself recover quickly
or
what am i doing wrong
to
create this unhealthy situation that i'm
in
you may get pictures in your head
i'm going to make these up for you the
listener
but you may get pictures in your head of
pizza
mcdonald's
you know not mcdonald's but hamburger
you might get a big m
you know i'm not knocking mcdonald's in
this case i'm just saying that you will
get a picture
you might get a picture if you take
pills of you swallowing all the pills in
one go
and it's telling you
that
this shouldn't happen
you should pause and take your pills
slowly
over a period of
minutes or talk or whatever the period
of time is
and your soul
will know the answers
so your guide is giving you the
information
your soul is
giving you
back
the answers
if you're open to listening
i'm not doing the sign of the cross
you think i'm
just connecting with my guide
so your guide will tell you
the answers you wish to know
i'm going to do an outward breath and
come out of this state now
so if you have a good connection
and it takes time like everything you
may be a lucky person and get an instant
uh
wow light bulb moment
and connect with your guide but normally
you have to get used to them they have
to get used to you
they would have been with you all your
life but you might not have been
listening or even needing them at the
time or believing in them or you might
not even believe in them now but just go
along with it and see what happens
i was talking about osensee and aikido
and the other films
he believed in this and when he called
upon the kameh to help him
it was as if
they showed him all the
directions
in the technical path
to have non-conflicts by non-conflict he
could do amazing feats because he was
never banging his head against the wall
but making a smooth passage
through a windy river
a windy whoever perhaps of mental
confusion
he could see it clearly
he could see when it had to be turned
and twisted and because it would all
happen so fast he had to rely
that he would be guided by his own soul
because of the information that the
camera gave his soul
so he stored this information
and he asked his body to react on the
information the soul would instruct
so instead of the ego mind being the
dominant force of
i will do this and i will do that
he was the peaceful butterfly
and he's
and the soul that gained all the
information from the different gods
the same as i've been talking about my
guide
he would say i offer you the use of my
body
to guide through this
pathway this river this storm
that's almost an impossibility for us to
do
i think so anyhow
but that's what i truly believe i truly
believe
that he gave over
his body
to the spirits to guide him
he said look
you're only in spiritual form
i'm in
physical form
please have the use of my body
and i with my eyes and heart will follow
and enjoy what you show me
and i truly believe this and i believe
that that's what's making and slowly
building my keto into the direction i
wish it to go
i hope you found this of interest
i know that those of you listened
to all of the films that i've been
talking about on this subject will have
been interested or you just would have
been like others
so there's a minority
the same as when i post yoga videos
meditation videos
on
my aikido
channel
if i'm if i get
over over 20 hits
over a year
that's not quite that long but it's
surprising
and yeah i put an aikido one on today
and by tomorrow
it might have 200 hits
an old saying in my time those
who are so blind that they cannot see
comes to mind
there's a lot more going on than
any of us can comprehend or think of
and i'll just let you into my mind and
my thoughts
and some of you
may
wish to
explore it for yourself
if you do explore it but you have
difficulties or you have questions
come back to me ask me i may be able to
help i may be able to answer
if not i'll ask my spirit guide
please answer this question
i'm going to end by saying that
if there is a god
he's in
she's in whatever it is you believe in
they're not in the physical form
and they can only help
by
giving you their thoughts
they can't tell you what to do they've
had their time on this planet
it's up to us now
to change
things because we have the physical
sadly with the yin and yang the good and
the bad seems to be here to stay
and the bad seem to be more destructive
than the good
and it's a sad
way around but
it is what it is
thank you for listening and i hope that
if we're guided by our spirits we can
all start to live a better life
and on on the planet
while we're here
thank you for your time